you
shortly after the release of the new
Fiesta Ford is now presenting the sports
car version of this compact the Ford
Fiesta ST it's supposed to be faster and
more fuel-efficient than its predecessor
montes cora tested it for us he notes it
drives very differently from a standard
fiesta with a very direct feeling for
the road an extremely responsive
steering everything is very direct the
gear gate is short and the pedals
respond fast the brakes are also a bit
more direct than in the normal Fiesta
garage says he has a very good
impression that's not on the equity
night the exterior of the Fiesta ST
displays flowing lines especially on the
hood new and all the models is the large
trapezoid shaped radiator grille with
its striking honeycomb structure Ford
engineer Juergen garsh daughter
described some of the cars new
developments the springs and shocks are
new and the wheel carriers are modified
in two ways their geometry results in
different camber values on the front
axle and the steering's new link
attachment point gives the st more agile
steering than the normal fiesta you know
us link fide and there's plenty of power
under the hood
Fiesta ST and North psst Epsom Cottage
doctor is proud of Ford's 1.6 liter
ecoboost four-cylinder direct injection
gasoline engine fancy motor to blow off
kaladan yeah it has 182 horsepower
twenty percent more than last year's
model diesel eyes with a twenty percent
improvement in fuel efficiency its young
model leaked on file at Swansea for 10
days and cough cough as partners the 1.6
liter EcoBoost engine produces a
substantial 134 kilowatts enabling it to
sprint to 100 kilometers an hour and 6.9
seconds top speed is 220 km/h the car
consumes an acceptable 5.9 liters for
100 kilometers
the rising line of the windows in the
1.5 centimeters lower chassis underscore
the st sportiness
a look from the side shows how
aerodynamic the st's roof line is the
rear spoiler is shores there's enough
contact pressure during the ride
the lights are LEDs
a chrome-plated double pipe exhaust
system in the rear and a sound symposia
the optimal sound level during your
drive the interior of the Fiesta ST is
well ordered and easily surveyed the
materials are well-crafted if we're
going to nitpick the many buttons on the
dashboard could be a little disturbing
the driver can see what's around him
adequately two-tone recaro bucket seats
keep even a sporty driver solidly in
place montes our tester discovered
something special about this theory only
does the car respond to the slightest
touch it also deals well with fast
driving and curves Ford's engineers have
built a torque vectoring system into the
car when the car enters a curve at high
speed the inside wheel is braked which
helps steer the vehicle into the curve
so the car can take curves faster and
stay under control better to follow
local Englishman disk i/o das Auto Black
Tide Fox besa in des por the st sport
chassis is very taut and transmits every
irregularity in the road to the driver
and passengers if the road is slippery
the ESP system which is standard
equipment engages early but the driver
can also shut the ESP off mata says the
fiesta is one of the best of the sporty
compacts he likes its appearance its
handling and it's right it's evolved as
the ophtho can get out South fastest
handling on thus far none gate the basic
Ford Fiesta ST cost nineteen thousand
nine hundred ninety euros in Germany add
leather upholstery and the price rises
by 1000 euros but that's still lower
than a comparable Golf GTI
applies vehicle in dark our tester Sasha
coupe is lamenting the cold snap that's
keeping spring at bay throughout much of
Europe snowy weather like this he says
nothing beats an SUV with a four-wheel
drive he's testing out the land rover
evoque when the innovator hits my pull
the fob reseeding makes for a smooth
entrance a press of a button is all it
takes to get going the gear stick risk
elegantly in the center console we're
testing out the minimalist SD for diesel
Range Rover with 140 kilowatts on tap it
takes eight and a half seconds to hit
the speed of 100 kilometers an hour the
maximum speed is 195 within the Evoque
range all but the smallest diesel models
are four wheel drives sasha says he
immediately feels much safer in a
four-wheel drive whether he's on or
opera but he's not convinced by the
automatic transmission offered by the
land rover evoque he says switching
gears takes too long and thinks that any
dual clutch transmission would be much
superior he says the car brakes for what
feels like a full second before it gets
going again fortunately all of the
diesel models are also available with a
manual 6-speed gearbox the only model
exclusively offering automatic
transmission is the 177 kilowatt petrol
engine
the focus on two ticket Linda sasha says
that among SUVs the ewok is definitely
the best off-roader though he wasn't
keen to disturb the wildlife during his
test drive he did want to see how the
Evoque would cope with steep climbs and
curves to do that he headed to a test
ground a few days ago we put the Ewok to
the test in a quarry close to dusseldorf
in western Germany
the first test immediately showed off
the advantages of the hill descent
control system when it comes to
controlled descent in rough terrain
bigger models have nothing on the Evoque
generous ramps and slope angles as well
as high ground clearance provide
stability
all engine variants are available in
both 3 door coupe a and 5-door bodies
the 5-door level is available in three
trim levels
hyosung Sasha can obsess the trim level
he's testing has a lot to offer
including optional steering wheel
heating which can be adjusted on the
side but he's not a fan of the full
leather which he says is revealed on
closer inspection by touch and feel he
doesn't think the price justifies the
imitation fittings meet artists on the
spinning insulated hood cologne gotta
buy dem pies the most luxurious or
prestige trim level kupe starts at forty
eight thousand three hundred seventy
euros in Germany a thousand euros more
than the five-door model not quite what
you'd expect but the slick appearance
and sporty image come more into play
than what's saved by losing the two
doors d copia form the sea volkmar sasha
says the shape of the coop egg gives it
a slick look but he's not very impressed
with the high windows at the back which
he says are too small I make him feel
cramped this flight from yahoo he says
they make it difficult for a child
particularly those under five to be seen
I'm stating lesson mr. he also says
getting people into the back of the car
is a real hassle as it takes a long time
to put the seat forward even then
there's only marginally more room some
cool missoni physically and society the
thought of installing a child's car seat
at the back is rather unappealing onan
little sasha says that to move the seat
forward again you need to keep the
button press down but he says that
there's so little space in the back that
even children wouldn't be very
comfortable their long journeys would be
especially challenging so motto
he can't get back in the front seat
quick enough after one final spin
through the snow our tester gives his
final verdict
gotta body says that when it comes to
safety in this kind of weather four
wheel drives are unbeatable the advice
is changing gear manually to avoid the
delays associated with an automatic
transmission finally his tip is to save
the 1000 euros and get the five-door
model as it's worth it to avoid making
getting in and out into an ordeal the
new four-door Mercedes CLA coupe a
brings a breath of fresh air into the
compact car range CLA is based on the a
class platform but with the proportions
of the Mercedes CLS its flattish profile
frameless doors and power packing lines
given a sporty look there's a choice of
diesel or three petrol engines prices
and Germany started twenty nine thousand
euros korean carmaker kia has released
its new karen's the compact van was
designed in Germany it's elegant and
balanced proportions and understated
style elements harmonize well the 100
kilowatt 1.7 crdi diesel engine powers
the 6 gear manual shift version from 0
to 100 kilometers an hour in 11 seconds
the Karen's hits dealerships and made
this year
classic roadsters all come from England
don't they well at the end of the 1930s
the BMW 328 a sporty roadster from
Bavaria struck fear into the heart of
the competition I [ __ ] saw test
driver Christoph Bowers is driving a
pre-war car over mountain passes or
through narrow alleyways like here at
Buena normally gives a driver a guilty
conscience for abusing his vehicle but
the 328 can take it all in stride it
drives extremely smoothly shifts without
complication and has plenty of power it
doesn't feel like a pre-war model at all
what led to the powerful 328 was not
hopes for a best-selling car but racing
ambitions in the 30s 80 horsepower from
two litres of engine displacement was a
real sensation in 1936 with the 328 BMW
opened a new chapter in sports car
history the compact two-seater set the
bar for hugging the road handling and
temperament competing sports cars with
twice the power were outdone
the 328 dominated its class in
Motorsports to the degree that there was
a question which driver but not which
car model would win these races no 328
no trophy the 328 also shown at the
Mille Miglia push coupon hun Stein and
vulgar boy amar won that race with it in
1940
our test drivers sighs with pleasure
this car has good sports genes that is
simply fun the 328 was very successful
on the track but there it looked a
little different from our very an
elegant convertible chassis like this
one was built for what today is called
the consumer marketing which was very
small back then Krista Bauer says these
forms might make you think this must
have been built by English craftsman but
the chassis was built by the Ludwig
Weinberger company in Munich in Oakland
good old Bavaria quantum and Sunnah of
the smaller the various colossal revine
burger successfully crossed a sports car
and a luxury convertible as in the basic
roadster the hood is secured with
leather straps and the rear wheels are
encased in gleaming metal the 328 was
built only 464 times and only 59 of the
vehicles have a chassis built by an
external specialist
no one talked about ergonomics back in
the 30s the flat doors and the oversized
steering wheel can find the driver like
a corset but the beautiful Bavarian
vehicle is still the very incarnation of
the idea of the Roadster
a 50 horsepower BMW 326 engine is the
basis but the engineers made many
modifications teasing a whopping 80
horsepower from the 328 6-cylinder
standard engine
Kristoff Bauer says that about the only
record the 328 didn't set was for sales
with just 464 built but in motorsports
it was the undisputed king and it was
all based on the technological mastery
that you still feel when you drive it
today this car was definitely a
milestone thought of yet in the fan is
Jesus auto definitive and manage time
bye